I can't find the exact comment,
but somebody's asked me multiple times
what products I use for my curls.
I've posted the video of how I do my hair,
and then these are the products I use.
This the curl cream I use.
It's by Pacifica.
Pineapple Swirl Curl Defining Cream by Pacifica.
This is the first thing I use on, like,
really wet hair.
Then this is the mousse that I really like,
the Pantene Soft Curls Shaping Mousse.
This is the mousse that I use.
Like, I posted the video.
And then if I really wanted to hold
and I really wanted to be this curly,
I finished with the not your mother's curl talk.
These three.
These are the only things that get my hair
to look like this.